découvrez-en icinéma come home ntoum
je n'aurais jamais dû le laisser
entraîner là dedans j'avais accroché il
ya un traceur sur la clé 10 abonnés
on ne s'est pas déjà vu tu te
souviendras moi elle est douée [ __ ]
elle est tournée
voilà aéroport de capetown à 21h elle a
l'air d'être aguerris au combat sûrement
une ancienne militaire c'est ce que je
sais c'est qu'elle est pleine de
surprises
elle me plaît beaucoup c'est lui
ça fait maintenant six ans que je dois
vivre caché
il est temps pour moi de sortir de norma
derrière toi
tu me fais confiance maintenue
ni maintenant
n'est jamais
comme momento le thé le 13 novembre au
cinéma / au service de vidéo à la
demande
exclusivement chez vous